mexico city's latest effort to stop us
still rampaging kovid 19
rapid testing booths set up in points
around the capital
like this one outside the famous azteca
football stadium
they're free although the results take
about five days to arrive
chef manuel lopez wishes they'd been
available much earlier
it's been done but perhaps this should
have come sooner it would have helped to
prevent this pandemic because we needed
this many months before
that way we would have avoided a lot
more infections
the city governments also introduced
these qr codes
which registered the phone numbers of
customers at shops and restaurants
so they can be told if they've come into
contact with anyone infected
this is the way to stop the virus the
capital's authorities
have finally concluded testing and
tracing
just like the world health organization
said months ago
but outside of mexico city the federal
government still isn't convinced
the country's got one of the lowest
testing rates in the world
and the coronavirus sar says that after
a certain point
tracing doesn't really work
meanwhile the mexican death rate is one
of the highest in the world 800 more
fatalities were announced just on
wednesday
and more than 100 000 people have died
in total
and things are getting worse not better
but president andres manuel lopez
obrador is still not convinced that a
police lockdown is the answer
its effectiveness hasn't been fully
demonstrated
many times lockdowns are carried out to
exalt the authoritarian attitude of an
official
you have to trust the people many in the
informal sector
which makes up more than half of
mexico's workforce would agree with him
they have no safety net if they're
forced to stay home and the government
hasn't brought out a wide-ranging aid
package to help them
they have to go out and work what the
government has put money into
is hospital beds so far mexico hasn't
run out of those
there are however a lot of questions
over the quality of equipment
and the service the overstretched
medical staff are able to provide
and the infections go on john holman al
jazeera mexico city